oh
wow
get your get your leg up
shocking video of a drug bust shows
police apprehending a suspect who was
hiding inside a dryer hide him in the
dryer
what are you doing dude
the bust happened on May 6th at a home
in Elyria Ohio about 35 minutes west of
Cleveland investigators there found
seven suspects wanted in connection for
drug charges the suspect in the dryer
wasn't the only one hiding though others
were found under blankets and in the
Attic hey come down it won't hurt you
man whoever you is get down here
wherever you is
Prospect
who else is out there
is it normal to hide in the Attic
yeah
come on come on
turn around push your hands on your back
it's Jimmy wake up bud come on dude
wake up can you stand back up for me
please
you're not under arrest just stand up
for me police identified the man in the
dryer as Michael McCloskey Jason Smith
was the one found under blankets
Stephanie Price in the attic and Brandon
Sherrill Under the Stairs
oh
you really think we're that dumb get up
stand up
no come out surreal can even be seen on
body camera video lighting up a
cigarette moments before he's handcuffed
don't worry about your cigarette let's
go
on
foreign
ERS found fentanyl methamphetamine
cocaine marijuana Xanax and other drug
paraphernalia inside the home all seven
suspects now face criminal charges some
on outstanding warrants and others on
charges of drug possession reporting for
long crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie